[Music]
on this Wednesday night Ukraine's
president shames the UN Security Council
it is preciser inequality that renders
the UN ineffective what viadimir
zalinski called Russia and what he's
urging the UN to do trans rights are
human rights dueling demonstrations I
don't want my grandchildren being taught
this
transgender agenda Nationwide protests
over gender diversity policies in
schools deepening diplomatic dispute
India's influence and a new warning
about Canada plus pride and Prestige for
a picturesque Place why a Quebec island
has been declared a UNESCO world
heritage
site glal National with Donna frezon
good evening and thanks for joining us
Ukraine's president took on Russia at
United Nations security Council today
calling for it to be stripped of its
veto power in an impassioned speech
Vladimir zalinsky said Russia has
violated un principles and is a
terrorist state that has rolled out a
criminal and unprovoked
Invasion 574 days of the full-fledged
Russian aggression means 574 reasons for
changes in this chamber humankind no
longer Ops its hopes on the UN when it
comes to the defense of The Sovereign
borders of
Nations Russia is one of the five
permanent members of the security
Council has veto power and has used it
to reject any resolutions that condemn
Moscow prime minister Justin Trudeau is
also at the UN today part of a 10
session ahead of zelinsky's planned
visit to Ottawa on Friday McKenzie gray
has our top story tonight president zi
do you arriving to fight for his
country's survival Ukrainian President
Vladimir zalinski was set to speak at a
special un security council meeting
objective is to conduct a meeting as
that was quickly interrupted by the
Russians claiming unsuccessfully zinski
should be B if you agree you stop the
war and president zalinski will not take
the floor the Russians didn't take that
offer which allowed the Ukrainian
president to call for Russia to be
stripped of its Security Council veto V
to right should not serve those who are
obsessed with hatred and War an idea
that was unsurprisingly dismissed by the
Russian foreign minister the right to a
veto is an absolutely legitimate
instrument which is stipulated in the
chart of the United Nations to prevent
the adoption of decisions that would
divide the organization zelinsky's
request Was Heard by mainly beist
Western Representatives with only Canada
Japan and Germany sending their leaders
to the meeting so we need to be 100%
clear about what is happening right now
a permanent member of this Security
Council Russia
has launched and continues to wage an
illegal War US President Joe Biden was
the only leader of the five countries
with veto power to attend the general
assembly but left before the Ukraine
debate we must send a clear message not
only to Russia but to all would be
aggressors that we will stand up not
stand by when the rules that we all
agreed to are being challenged but how
the US stands up in the future is
becoming more uncertain with the
majority of Americans and an
overwhelming number of Republicans now
opposing future Aid being sent to Keef
the length of time the war has gone on
the lack of significant progress any big
breakthrough um has contributed to a
waning of support outside of Ukraine
Justin Trudeau had five one-on-one
meetings today including with the
leaders of Germany and Italy and a
government Source says the Prime
Minister brought up India and foreign
interference in each one of those
conversations Donna all right McKenzie
gray at the UN in New York thanks
president zilinsky will be in Washington
tomorrow it's expected he'll get an
additional $325 million in military aid
though support for sending Ukraine even
more help is on Shaky Ground there as
Russia's War rages on and a second
winter of fighting is approaching a
strong Russian defense is making any
Frontline gains nearly impossible
Crystal ganing
Reports apocalyptic battle scenes are
front and center in eastern Ukraine near
bakut Ukraine is trying to reclaim land
from Russian forces but it is a
Monumental task letting the war drag on
is a huge
mistake us businessman and
philanthropist Howard Buffett has spent
Millions helping injured Ukrainian
soldiers but fears the West has War
fatigue allies know it and are trying to
combat it Ukraine has not asked any
other country to fight for them all
they're asking for is help help longterm
is reaffirmed by those supporting
Ukraine including Canada before
attending a meeting in Germany defense
minister Bill Blair met with Canadian
Armed Forces members training ukrainians
in the UK Blair says Canadians
understand what is at stake and that
Canada has more to offer much more work
needs to be done and those announcements
will be coming in the coming weeks
Ukraine's front line reportedly
stretches over 1,000
kilomet that's roughly the driving
distance from Vancouver to
bamp Ivan says his biggest fear is the
Russians will reach his hometown a
thought
interrupted by an explosion Russia is
not just defending what it has taken
from Ukraine but is pushing for more
military experts say strikes on enemy
Supply chains can be useful to buy time
and disrupt strategic plants an oil
Depot in Sochi was hit by a drone strike
early Wednesday the latest Russian site
to be targeted Ukraine has not claimed
responsibility Crystal ganing Global
News
London the British prime minister is
walking back on some key promises on
climate policy saying British consumers
are not ready to Bear the costs attached
to them I'm confident that we can adopt
a more pragmatic proportionate and
realistic approach to meeting Net Zero
that eases the burdens on working people
Richi sunak is rolling back climate
measures he's deferring a ban on the
sale of new gas and diesel cars from
20130 to 2035 delaying the phasing out
of gas boilers and homes Energy
Efficiency targets for landlords will
also be scrapped along with planned
insulation requirements for homeowners
sunak insists the UK's Net Zero Target
of of 2050 will still be reached but the
move has been met with despair by
climate scientists and environmental
experts who say it will cost consumers
more in the long run relations between
India and Canada have hit a new low
India has now issued a travel advisory
for Canada it warns Indian Nationals of
what it calls growing anti-india
activities and politically condoned hate
crimes and criminal violence in Canada
it's all part of the Indian government's
angry response to prime minister Justin
trudo's allegation India may be behind
the killing of a sick leader in BC Toria
isri reports on the worsening Diplomatic
relationship India is warning its
citizens Canada could be a dangerous
place a threat assessment the Canadian
government strongly disagrees with
people can read into that what they want
Canada is a safe country other MPS were
more blunt sounds like a
joke India's min Ministry of external
Affairs issued a travel advisory for
Indian Nationals in Canada because of
what it calls an anti- India agenda
given the deteriorating security
environment in Canada Indian students in
particular are advised to exercise
Extreme Caution I know a couple family
members checked in but aside from that
there's nothing but I haven't seen any
hate crimes since this situation
unfolded today I'm rising on Monday
prime minister Justin Trudeau linked
Indian agents to the assassination of
Canadian Citizen and sick leader Hardeep
Singh nider so since then both countries
have kicked out
diplomats and now Delhi is urging
caution on Canadian campuses last year
Canada issued just shy of 226,000 visas
to Indian students more than any other
country accounting for 41% of study
permits it's somewhat symbolic but it's
also a I would argue you an attempt at
using what India understands to be a
huge um instrument of of economic
leverage in a deepening diplomatic
dispute Trudeau insists Canada has
credible intelligence India may be
behind the killing the opposition wants
proof the Canadian government must share
the evidence that they have somebody
who's been in National Security Experts
say that might compromise the murder
investigation for the Prime Minister
himself to stand up on the opening of of
a session of Parliament that shows that
that the government has a high degree of
confidence and while tensions are
escalating between both countries by the
day so far Global Affairs has no plans
on changing its travel advisory for
Canadian citizens in India Donna okay
Tria isri in Ottawa thanks a series of
organized protests across Canada today
targeted sex education in schools and
the rights of queer and trans children
the organizers claim so-called gender
ideology is being taught in schools and
that children are being indoctrinated
and sexualized counter-protesters pushed
back against that saying the group is
trying to roll back the clock on human
rights and is fostering regressive
policies that will lead to hatred and
violence against queer and trans people
politicians are pushing back too BC's
Premier tweeting there is no room for
hate in BC schools and that school must
be a place where all students staff and
families belong and feel safe and where
respect is shown for each other's
differences prime minister Justin
Trudeau tweeting transphobia homophobia
and biophobia have no place in this
country we strongly condemn this hate
and its
manifestations David Baxter is in Ottawa
where protesters turned up on Parliament
Hill David what happened there well Don
over a thousand protesters and counter
protesters came out to Parliament today
it all started with what people are
calling the 1 million March for children
now these are people saying that they're
standing up against gender ideology
indoctrination and kids well that's what
they are calling it and the counter
protesters came up to say they're here
to stand up for Trans kids eventually it
led to about a 90-minute standoff with
police separating the two sides as they
hurled conflicting chance at each other
take a
listen right are
[Applause]
human
silence
as you can see there that initial
protest began to March down El Elgen
Street away from Parliament Hill and
after that people began to disperse
around here now similar scenes unfolded
across Canada taken to listen to what
protesters on both sides had to say in
Victoria I'm here to protect my
grandchildren from uh any sexual
orientation in schools it's wrong our
kids deserve to be
innocent not the school telling the
parents how to raise their kids I think
it's misguided and I think there's some
confusion about maybe what we do in
schools um what we teach is inclusivity
so that every person can see themselves
reflected in their school and their
school material David those who organize
this March claim they're protecting the
Innocence the safety of children plenty
of people though think it's exactly the
opposite yes Donna and that's exactly
what brought the counter protesters out
today including the NDP caucus in Ottawa
jug me Singh was actually part of the
line leading the counter protest March
up Parliament Hill I spoke with him just
before that about the gender policies in
New Brunswick and Saskatchewan schools
it shows the bullies that the
conservatives are and shows that they're
not actually dealing with the problems
that people are faced with and are
trying to create Division and pick
fights with vulnerable people now lgbtq
plus Advocates say this is about
protecting vulnerable youth in schools
and now a University of Ottawa Study
last year found that trans kids are five
times more likely to think about suicide
and seven times more likely than their
to attempt it than their cisgender peers
Don all right David Baxter in Ottawa
thanks fall is almost here that means
flu season is not far behind coming up
what that means for
you there's more Fallout tonight from
the controversial Green Belt land swap
in Ontario a second cabinet minister in
Premier Doug for's government has
resigned khed rashed the minister of
public and Business Service delivery is
leaving both cabinet and caucus during
the Integrity commissioner's Green Belt
land swap investigation Rasheed was
asked about a 2020 trip to Las Vegas
with the premier's then principal
secretary and a prominent land developer
all three told the commissioner they
went on separate trips but CTV News
reported they stayed in the same hotel
and got massages at the same time
earlier this month Ontario's housing
Minister also resigned from cabinet over
the plan to remove Land from the
protected green belt around Toronto so
developers can build housing Co gold and
flu season is on the horizon along with
a new subvariant of Co 19 detected in
Canada in August it has Health experts
worried Canada's Health Care system
could be overloaded like last year
Katherine Ward explains what you can do
to prepare flu season begins in April in
Australia and gives Canadians a glimpse
into the future so doctors watch that
data closely the numbers seem to be a
bit below or at the same level as prior
years preand mic um there was a kind of
early sharp rise and then a decline that
that happened a bit earlier than
expected but as our flu season
approaches doctors say getting that flu
shot is a tough cell I'm worried because
people are tired of vaccination they're
tired of coid shots and by extension
they're tired of all shots Dr Brian
Conway says vaccines are key to keeping
people out of the hospital if we let our
guard down and we have too low an uptake
of vac ination for Co and flu that
that'll lead to increased to
transmission and will potentially uh
stress the Health Care System more
significantly than it can bear 43% of
Canadians got a flu shot last year 74%
of seniors were vaccinated but that
falls short of the 80% coverage goal 21%
of those who didn't get a shot said they
just didn't get around to it making time
is critical especially for children
under two and those who are immuno
compromised says pediatric specialist Dr
Jesse papenberg roughly 15 to 20% of
children who get admitted actually
require ICU care so they are critically
ill and require some sort of ventilatory
support or other assistance in terms of
maintaining their uh vital and doctors
say while you're rolling up one sleeve
you might roll up the other and get an
updated Co 19 shot at the same time it's
important that we take the opportunities
when one vaccine is being administered
to make sure people are up to date let's
just uh one and done go get your vaccine
and uh maybe be part of the solution
Katherine Ward Global News
Toronto still ahead why five eyes
countries may be biting their tongues on
Canada's diplomatic clash with
India Canada's allies are walking a
diplomatic tight RPP after prime
minister Trudeau said India may have
been behind the killing of a sick leader
in BC the US UK and Australia all
expressed deep concern and said those
responsible should be held accountable
but they stopped short of publicly
condemning prime minister Narendra Mod's
government for its alleged role in The
Killing Modi is not only extremely
popular at home he leads a country
that's grown increasingly powerful Eric
Sorenson looks at where that leaves
Canada a diplomatic clash with India is
no small and it is India's moment to
shine Narendra Modi has emerged as a
powerful player on the world stage India
now the most populous country with a
booming economy modi's unabashed Hindu
nationalism has made him popular in a
nation with more than a billion Hindus
and at the G20 he was the host and the
star showing India's growing influence
in world affairs it's actually a very
great deal for our country people will
know what India is and what developments
we have made I'm feeling great about it
it's a proud moment for being an Indian
it's a proud moment for
when India landed on the moon there was
Modi on screen this success the World
Press Freedom index suggests Indian
media have become more concentrated more
partisan and more friendly towards Modi
they cheerlead Modi they have been
uncritical admirers of Mr Modi this
professor says it all helps Modi project
International influence India likes to
think that he's a very significant
player um in terms of India's
geopolitical
heft in purely diplomatic terms Canada
has taken on a heavyweight Modi is a
sought-after partner with Western
leaders who have not jumped to Canada's
side in spite of allegations of State
supported murder in this country it is
critical that Canada's investigation
proceeds and the perpetrators be brought
to justice is all that Washington would
say and from the UK we're in close touch
with our Canadian Partners about these
serious allegations it would be
inappropriate to comment further India
is being seen at least in the western
world as a strong bullwark against China
India is definitely on a former ground
that way because of its location because
everyone is trying to go India for now
Canada India relations are at a low
point and India is pushing back against
ottawa's allegations you're dealing with
an Indian government which won't take
this line down so I don't know what
happened in the case in this particular
case but uh we certainly take a very
strong View and until there's more
evidence that India was behind the
murder of a Canadian citizen it is
Justin Trudeau and not Narendra Modi who
seems more diplomatically isolated Eric
senson Global News
Toronto protected Paradise next to
Quebec Island becomes part of an
exclusive
[Music]
Club a Canadian island has a new badge
of honor it is now a UNESCO world
heritage site Quebec's anticosti Island
lies in the middle of the Gulf of St
Lawrence it's larger than Prince Edward
Island and has more than 550 km of
pristine Coastline its spectacular
unspoiled landscape has an abundance of
wildlife deep canyons and stunning
waterfalls but perhaps the most
important treasure is its exceptional
preservation of fossils Dan Spectre
reports it's 8,000 square kilometers of
unspoiled natural Splendor at the mouth
of the St Lawrence if Quebec's anti
costy Island was relatively unknown up
till now it's just made a grand entrance
to the world stage after a highly
anticipated decision on the other side
of the globe adopted congratulations to
State Canada that was the moment atiti
Island was named a UNESCO world heritage
site local politician mear was in Riad
Saudi Arabia for the announcement it was
such a special moment I was thinking
about the people on usty Island
and at a watch party in the Island's
only Town total
Elation it was a moment of immense Pride
says anti cost's mayor setting the eight
years of work it took for the tiny
community of just 200 people to reach
this
point the Island's stunning scenery will
take your breath away but it's not the
beauty that made it Canada's 22nd UNESCO
world heritage site it's what's in the
ground the state of preservation of the
fossil are exceptional and enable
worldclass scientific work Andre de was
the scientific director of the bid and
has studied the island since
1977 he and UNESCO say it possesses the
world's best preserved paleontological
record of the first mass extinction of
animal life around 440 million years ago
probably the most complete fossil record
of marine life uh from this period as
the new designation will spark a wave of
interest from the scientific Community
the island is expecting an influx of
tourists too anti costy only has room
for about 50 visitors at a time right
now we have a lot of work to do more
roads and infrastructure are on the way
so this now world-renowned Island can be
put on full display Dan Spectre Global
News
Montreal looks stunning and that is
global national for this Wednesday I'm
Donna freezen tonight's your CID is the
magdalin islands there part of the
province of Quebec but are actually
geographically closer to newfinland
thanks for watching for our Naser will
be at the anchor desk tomorrow and I
will see you again on Friday
[Music]
bye-bye